>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Erik Bertin: OK, I think
we're ready to resume.
The final program this afternoon
deals with Section 117 and 109.
And the topic is we'll be exploring
whether current limitations on
and exceptions to copyright
protection adequately address issues
concerning software
embedded in everyday products
or whether amendments or
clarifications would be useful.
I'd like to start with just
sort of a general observation
from having reviewed
all the comments.
And while this is not
a universal statement,
it does seem to be
fairly common that many
of the commenters either said that
no changes were warranted or needed,
on the one hand, and others
commenter said that the same thing
but qualified it by
saying that Sections 109
and 117 properly construed,
no changes are needed.
While that creates the appearance of
consensus, I suspect that somewhere
in the middle there is
some level of disagreement
which hopefully we'll
get into this afternoon.
So, I would throw that out as
sort of an opening question,
a general question of whether
changes are needed or not,
and if so-- if changes are needed
in the interpretation of 109 or 117,
what those areas of interpretation
where they would be helpful.
So perhaps we could start with 109
if anyone would like to jump in.
Jonathan? Jonathan Band, rather.
>> Jonathan Band: Sure.
So, I guess, you know, the sort
of like the threshold issue of,
you know, properly interpreted--
but, you know, properly
interpreted--
you know, if I were an
Article 3 judge, you know,
the world would be very
different, but that's--
I don't see that happening
any time soon.
And I think especially for
ORI, we're very focused
on the specific problem of
109A and how would applies
to software-enabled products.
And it seems that between the--
what is an owner and what is the
proper scope of interpretation
of 109A and all of these contractual
issues that we talked about,
the fact that you could just--
regardless of how courts
interpret 109A,
you could still have contractual
restrictions on transfer.
So we just think as
a practical matter,
the only way in the
foreseeable future to really deal
with this issue, you know,
and that's why you have--
with circuit splits
and all the rest is
to have something very
short and sweet like YODA.
And that would, you know,
it wouldn't obviously solve the
entire problem but it would solve,
you know, one piece of the problem.
>> Erik Bertin: Mr. Perzanowski?
>> Aaron Perzanowski: Yes,
I would agree that YODA
is an important first step
and does embody some
important principles.
I would also agree that it
doesn't solve the whole problem.
I think-- I would not recommend
any changes to the text of 109
or 117 relevant to
the particular set
of questions that we're addressing.
Today, what I do think would
be useful is a definition
in Section 101 of owner for
exhaustion purposes, right?
Owner of a copy as it appears in 109
and 117 or definition of transfer
of copy ownership, I think
that is a crucial question.
It is a question that courts have
answered in a lot of different
and I think inconsistent
ways over the years.
I think a definition of ownership
would provide some much needed
clarity, right?
Who are we talking about here?
We're talking about
consumers for the most part.
How do consumers know whether
they own the things that they buy?
I don't think it's a particularly
satisfying answer to tell them well,
you know, here's a dozen cases
decided by the Ninth Circuit
and the Federal Circuit
and the Second Circuit
and maybe you can make
sense of this question.
It's really fundamental question
and so I think it deserves some
attention here in terms of what
that definition would look like.
You know, if it were up to me, I
would have a definition that said
that anytime you had a
transaction that was characterized
by a one time payment
and perpetual possession
that is a transfer
of ownership, right?
So, that I think is the key
question that we have to answer here
with respect to 109 and 117.
I also included in my written
comments a couple of references
to the Canadian and Israeli
Copyright Acts and the way
that they deal with
the ROM copy doctrine
and temporary instantiations
of works transient copying.
I think there might be some benefit
from clarification there as well.
>> Erik Bertin: Mr. Band
mentioned the Your Own Devices Act
and suggested that would be a good--
I think Mr. Perzanowski said
it was a good first step.
What affect or impact if any do--
does anyone anticipate from--
if that legislation was passed, what
impact would it have on innovation
in the field of software for
embedded software for devices?
Mr. Kupferschmid?
>> Keith Kupferschmid: So
I think if the YODA bill
or something potentially similar
or worse were to be enacted,
I think it would certainly
adversely affect the ability
of software companies to
co-license, including the manner
in which these software companies
license as well as their ability
to enforce these licenses.
As a result, it will be
more challenging for them
to recoup their investment
they make to--
and to develop new software products
and to update existing ones.
It'll be more difficult for them
to widely distribute their software
products to the public especially
on a variety of different platforms
that consumers enjoyed today.
The availability of
scope and warranties--
scope of warranties
and support services,
I think could be adversely
affected as well.
It almost certainly would
change their pricing structure,
certainly given the
provisions on maintenance
and support that are in the bill.
And it could also allow
competitors to get access
to their software more readily
and therefore steal the software
of the underlying code and
create and sell cheap imitations
because they will not
have the sort of R&D costs
of the original software company.
>> Sy Damle: So, on
that last point, I mean,
why wouldn't just a regular
copyright infringement lawsuit be
sufficient there?
I mean, YODA doesn't
take away the ability
to bring in infringement suit?
>> Keith Kupferschmid:
So, yeah, no, I think--
I mean I think that's right, but
like I said, it would make it easier
so I don't think you
want to be in a position
where you've changed your business
model from instead of creating
and innovating to bringing
infringement suits either
and so I think that's--
it's becomes an issue
of how do you police the
software and similarly.
>> Sy Damle: But do you think
the licenses are actually is--
or what preventing
that's kind of theft?
>> Keith Kupferschmid: I would hope
to some extent that
that is the case.
I mean, certainly, well, like I
said, we'll talk about 1201 tomorrow
and that's part of it and I may
be sort of joining two bills,
the YODA bill and Fahrenholtz's
another draft that he's been working
on which would basically take
away the 1201 protections, so--
in doing so, but I think
certainly the combination
of the two would have that effect.
>> Sy Damle: So, can I ask--
sorry, just a general--
which maybe other people
can address which is--
which I've always just
been curious about,
but why the essential copy exemption
is limited to owners of the copies
and why that's not automatically?
So, CONTU recommended that Congress
adopt a rule that's, you know,
allows you to create essential
copies if you were the--
I think it was a lawful
possessor of the copy
and that was changed in
Congress to be owner.
I'm just wondering just
as a practical matter,
what's the rationale for limiting
the essential copy defends to owners
of software rather than
anyone who is, you know,
has a lawful possession
of the software?
Mr. Bergmayer?
>> John Bergmayer: I'm
happy to address that.
Well, as I look at the
essential step copy doctrine
as really making the most sense
and doing the most useful work
in the case of installing software,
which doesn't happen as much anymore
since people just typically just
installed over the internet.
But if you have a disk I would
say when you are installing--
you're installing from floppy
disks or a CD-ROM on to a computer,
well that is a copy, right, and I
think that is inarguably a new copy.
And if you own that disk, then
you should be able to use it
by installing it on a computer.
I mean, I don't think that's a
particularly controversial point
and that's where I think that the
essential step doctrine does the
most useful work.
Where I have sort of
trouble with it is the notion
that simply using software
creates a ROM copy
and using the essential step
test in that context, I think is,
it shouldn't be necessary to--
either those ROM copy should
be ephemeral and just excluded
from the definition of copy or
some other doctrine should say
that the possessor in that
context should not need to use--
need a license simply to use the
software, but I think limiting it
to the lawful owner is logical in
the case of installing software
because otherwise, I could take
software and then install it
on my computer and I'm the
lawful possessor then I lend it
to my friend, my friend
is the lawful possessor
because he is borrowing
it and he can install it
in his computer and so on.
So I think that limiting it to
owner in that particular concept--
contexts makes sense but not in the
context of ROM copies which I need--
I think needs to be more
fundamentally dealt with.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: Can I add?
>> Erik Bertin: Sure.
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
I think another point that's
important here is to keep in mind
that the owner of a copy stands
in a special relationship
to the work, right?
The owner of a copy is someone
who in the ordinary circumstance
has compensated the copyright holder
for that work, right?
And so it makes sense to extend
a set of rights to owners
that we don't extend, certainly
to the public generally, right?
Owners have rights that the
public at large shouldn't have.
And there might be other people who
are temporarily in lawful possession
of a copy that we don't think
deserve those protections, right?
So, you know, I order some software,
I don't know what decade this
hypothetical takes place in but we--
I order some software
over the internet
and it gets delivered
to me by FedEx.
FedEx is in lawful
possession of that software.
I don't think they get
to make copies of it even
if they're essential to running the
program because they don't stand
in that sort of relationship
with the copyright holder.
You know, the exhaustion is premised
in large part on this idea of,
you know, the single recovery
theory where, you know,
copyright holders have
been compensated
and as a result some rights
get transferred to consumers.
That's just not true for people who
might be, you know, like I said,
you know, temporarily in possession
or bailed users something
along those lines.
>> Erik Bertin: Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: A couple of things.
I think I just wanted
to associate myself
with Keith's remarks on software.
He hit all the bullets
that I'd written
down plus a couple more
I hadn't thought of.
The only thing I'm somewhat
confused about is we--
there's been some suggestion
that there's a split.
I'm not sure exactly which cases
we're talking about a split on
but if we're talking about--
I mean, if we're talking
about Crawl [assumed spelling]
and Vernor [assumed spelling], in
our view, there is simply no split.
And there is certainly no split
that warrants different application
of a newly crafted rule
to embedded software.
I mean I just-- I'm-- this is
something that I am struggling with.
I don't-- I just simply
don't see that.
>> Sy Damle: So, in
considering, one of the things
that Crawl I think says is
that you could consider--
so, it says that the terms
of the license aren't necessarily
controlling and that one
of the factors, I think,
it identifies whether
it's the software is sort
of embedded in the device.
I think they bring
that up as one factor.
Do you think that's an appropriate
factor for a court to look
at in terms of determining sort
of trying to draw this line
between licensing and ownership?
>> Chris Mohr: Right.
Appropriate, absolutely, right?
Because-- I mean this goes back
to the exchange that we, I guess,
indirectly had before about
consumer expectations.
There are particular industries
where there will be costumes
practices usage of trade
about how these goods
are sold and delivered.
In such cases, there is going
to be a good deal of reticence,
not only I think on the consumer
side but also on the judicial side
to engage in-- to find
ongoing license agreements
where they are in fact a fiction.
But there are going to be
a whole lot of other cases
where a licensing relationship
is completely appropriate.
And I mean, in our view, the courts
have solved that problem properly
and there's no indication that
they won't solve it properly
going forward.
>> Erik Bertin: Mr. Lowe?
>> Aaron Lowe: So I wanted to
comment the issue that's come
up about how innovation will
be affected by, you know,
the YODA or any revisions.
And I think, you know, our industry,
the whole vehicle off the marker
which is about $350 billion industry
in this country has expand
a huge amount of innovation
because of the ability to
reserve engineer and the ability
to work with, you know,
to work with patent law.
And patent is still available
to protect, you know, innovation
and protect new ideas but
the sense that you can use
that we fear is the use of
copyright law to inhibit that
and I guess I brought that
up before and, you know,
the issue of exhaustion one step for
sale the car owner should be the one
that owns all the software,
not necessarily the, you know,
the idea behind the software but the
software-enable to do what they want
with that vehicle and that
includes, be able to put on parts
from that car that may not
be made by the same person
or company that made the car.
So I think it's important that
when you're looking all this
that that needs to be considered
as part of this equation.
>> Erik Bertin: Just to bring to
Section 117 into the debate here.
Section 117 does give certain
rights of repair and maintenance,
but interestingly, the
language you use is--
that the key point is that you
have to be the owner of the machine
which in Mr. Lowe's example
would be the owner of the car.
Is ownership there-- is ownership
of the machine itself enough
or do we also have to
worry about the ownership
of the programs on the machine?
Mr. Band you're already
up, so go ahead.
>> Jonathan Band: So, I'll answer
that as well as the, you know,
the other questions on the table.
So, certainly, in my
view it should be--
and actually I think 117C is
it's the owner of the machine
or the owner or licensee of
the machine at least for 117C,
whereas 117B I think
applies to the, you know,
is the owner of the
software and that's part
of the problem here
that they're different.
And I think senate
leader, you're asking why
with CONTU what was the cause of the
change from what CONTU recommended
to what Congress enacted, you
know, I'm old, I'm not that old,
it was before my time when the
copyright software amendments were
enacted in 1980, but I suspect
that there's a very simple answer
that the lobbyist from
large computer
and software companies
understood that by shifting it
from lawful possessor
to lawful owner
that they dramatically narrowed
the effectiveness of 117
because by then already-- there
were, you know, already by then,
the predominant model was to license
software, and so they realized
that they could completely
neuter the effectiveness of 117
by just changing a couple of words.
So that's actually
pretty good lobbying.
You know, I wish I'd been
around and had done it.
But with respect to the question
about innovation, I don't think,
you know, a bill like YODA would
have any impact on innovation.
I mean, right now,
sort of this control
over the resale market
is sort of like money
that goes right to the bottom line.
A manufacturer knows that a product
has, you know, a certain lifespan.
They have no idea whether
the purchaser of that piece
of equipment is going to keep it
for its entire lifespan or sell it
after five years and then, you
know, someone else will use it
for the remaining two or
three years of the lifespan.
But the ability to charge
an extra license fee
for that transaction which, you
know, they wouldn't have made
if it just stayed in the
possession of the first purchaser.
I mean, that's just again money
that goes right to the bottom line.
I don't think it'll have
any impact on innovation.
The possibility of
infringement, again,
a bill like YODA makes it very clear
that, you know, the selling applies
to non-infringing copies and as
you mentioned that it also relate,
you still have the ability
to sue for infringement.
>> Sy Damle: So as YODA, just
going back to sort of a point
that I was making-- a
question I had before
about whether this was limited, sort
of enterprise level kinds of things.
Is it your-- and so YODA would
have extend to all of those, right,
it wouldn't just be
limited to consumer devices,
it would also extend to, you know,
a $20,000, you know, rack server.
Yeah, right?
>> Jonathan Band: Right.
>> Sy Damle: Yeah.
>> Jonathan Band: It
would be-- it would be--
because at this point when you're
having, you know, it would apply
to the, you know, to the iPhone,
it would have apply to this.
>> Sy Damle: Right.
>> Jonathan Band: And
again we're talking--
and when you say enterprise level,
I mean, you know, you have a lot
of government agencies, you
know, this Library of Congress,
but it could also be the tree
company that's, you know,
that was chopping down trees
in my neighborhood yesterday.
I mean, a lot of the power
saws have software in them now.
And so if you want to
startup, one guy wants to start
up his own company and buy
used power saws, you know,
it would allow him to start
a new business as well.
>> Sy Damle: And is it your-- So
it wouldn't be necessarily limited
to circumstances where there's
like an ability to engage and sort
of the first purchaser
to engage in negotiation.
I mean, let me put this put
it different way, it's to--
to what extent is there a kind
of, I mean, maybe you know,
maybe you don't know, is
there sort of negotiation
between a company purchasing a
kind of-- you know, blips of that.
I know you don't like
the word enterprise,
but enterprise level kind of,
you know, switch from Cisco
and the first purchaser and Cisco
this like negotiating over the terms
of the license, like how
does just never happened?
>> Jonathan Band: My impression
is it happens very, very rarely.
I mean I imagine when the federal
government is buying things
from Cisco, there probably
is a negotiation.
But certainly going back to, you
know, when and this does date me
but when I was working on UCITA,
the, you know, the understanding was
that even you have these large
insurance companies, you know,
when they were dealing with
the software vendors, you know,
this are like AETNA and MetLife.
There was no negotiation, there
was very much to take early
that this is the license,
you got to take--
you got to take the
deal and that's one
of the reasons why the insurance
industry was so involved
in the fight against UCITA
and base ultimately prevented
from being adopted anywhere other
than Maryland and Virginia was
because they-- there was no
negotiation even for, you know,
these Fortune 50 companies.
>> Mr. Bergmayer.
>> John Bergmayer: Yeah, this
have a-- just a sort of--
sort of a clarification
and some curious
as to how other people view this.
I mean when I read the
definition of a copy,
it says it's a material object, so
I would say that if own the car,
I necessarily own any copies
of software in that car,
unless you could say that there
are physically parts of the car
that I own and physically parts
of the car that I don't own.
Because I can't sort of I don't
understand how you can read the
statute in any other way.
So if I own the car, I
own the copies in the car
or if I own the machine
I own the copies
that are contained in the machine.
Or if you say that I own the
machine and I don't own the copies,
there are physically parts, there
are literally chips or portions
of the physical item that I
don't own well I do own the rest,
and how do I pick out, which
ones I do and which ones I don't.
I mean this is just how
the statute is written.
This is the entire basis of how all
of these interrelated statutes work.
And I keep hearing this notion
that well, you own the machine
but you don't own copies
of software in the machine,
and that just doesn't make any sense
and it just doesn't
comport with the statute.
>> Sy Damle: And so I mean, but--
and so I mean do you think
the Congress when they--
when Congress reacted to the MAI
case, do you think they were just--
they were-- what do
you think that meant?
Were they not implicitly sort of
accepting that the premise of,
you know, of software ownership
versus machine ownership wasn't
actually a real distinction
or what--
>> John Bergmayer: It
says that if you own--
>> Sy Damle: -- how
do you react to that?
>> John Bergmayer: I mean, I'm
just looking at the statute,
as if you own the machine,
then if there is a new copy
in other words something that
does trigger a copyright,
that is made by virtue of activating
the machine then you were given a
statutory license to make that
copy, so that is not really relating
to the nature of what a copy is
or whether you own it or not.
There's nothing in it that
says you don't own the copy.
It's authorizing you
to make a new copy.
So I think that's fine
and it does say a machine
that lawfully contains an authorized
copy, so that would seemed to sort
of say you could have a
machine and parts of the count
as the material object that is the
copy, and parts of it that don't.
But if we're going to say that you
don't own the copy but you do--
but you do own the machine,
then that necessarily requires
that you have some
way of determining,
which parts of the machine
do I own and which parts
of the machine don't I own.
Because again, that's just
what the statute it says,
there's no other way to read
it that actually does justice
to the actual words
that Congress enacted.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Harbeson.
>> Eric Harbeson: I just-- I'm
not going to have a lot to say
about Section 117 based
of my membership of course
but I do want to make two points.
The first is that there was another
case that was decided the same day
as Vernor, and that's the UMG
v. Troy Augusto which is a case
of distribution of promotional
CDs to radio stations via
from record labels, and that
case was decided in favor of--
in favor of the person
who is doing the selling.
To my knowledge it is not
affective market for CDs.
So I-- And I offer that only
because it seems relevant to me,
but I recognize that I'm a
little bit off point here.
The other thing is I want to respond
to some points that were made
on this side of the table regarding
to-- with regarding to piracy.
And just to point out that, you
know, I have some experience
with the concept of piracy,
I've been accused of this table
of being a pirate in previous
hearings and I, you know,
we make laws for the law abiding
not for the people that don't.
If someone who's going to
violate a license is going
to violate the copyright
they don't care.
The people who this will affect
or the people who do want
to follow the lawsuit, so I just
like to remind people of that.
That's probably all I
say with this panel.
>> Eric Bertin: General question.
If Congress decided to enact YODA or
some other legislation of a similar
or different nature or made
other changes that, you know,
like haven't suggested here stay.
Is there a risk or concern that
Congress that should be aware
of that private parties which
is simply contract around them,
say well not withstanding
the provisions
of the now newly amended 109 or 117,
you are not considered an owner.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: I'm
happy to start to address that.
As I recall, I don't have the text
of YODA memorized but I do think
that the bill contemplates that
the possibility of contracting
around those rights and it
explicitly rejects that possibility.
So, I think this is really
important to go back to the point
that someone made earlier
about the distinction
between a contract and a license.
A license is fundamentally
a creature of property law,
not a creature of contract law.
And, you know-- if what has
happened is a transfer of ownership
as a matter of property law, a
contract doesn't change that right?
It might create contract
liability for breach,
but I don't think it can change
that fundamental question
of the transfer of ownership.
That's why I think it's really
important do we have a clear,
well settled understanding
of what kinds
of property transactions
trigger a transfer of ownership?
That's not a function of contract.
The other point that I
wanted to make is, you know,
in some of the earlier panels we
had some discussion about, you know,
concrete examples of harm to
consumers and whether we can--
whether we can point
to specific instances
where consumers have been prevented
from transferring their devices
or whether we can articulate
other kinds of harm.
And I think we can, but I
also think it's important
to use the same standard in
evaluating harm when we're talking
about the sort of potential
future harms to consumers
which I agree have not all
materialize yet and the kinds
of speculative harms that have
been articulated when it comes
to passing legislation
like YODA, right?
I think we need to hold those two
kinds of harm to the same standard.
>> Sy Damle: So can I ask you about
sort of the Crawl test which starts
from the premise that the terms
of the license are not
necessarily controlling the relevant
but not necessarily
controlling and that--
and at least in that case the court
kind of went beyond the four corners
of the contract to look
at the kind of the--
the sort of facts on the ground to
determine whether there was the--
there was a license or there
where there was ownership.
I mean, do you think that that test
is sufficiently clear or is in sort
of an appropriate approach
for courts to take
and try to draw this line?
>> Aaron Perzanowski: So.
I think the-- I think
the Crawl test by looking
at the terms of the license.
Is not mistaken, right, to take
those terms into consideration.
I think what's crucial
though is trying to figure
out exactly what question
we're trying to answer.
And the question we're trying to
answer is not, what are the hopes
and dreams of the copyright
holder that they have reflected
in this agreement which is I think
what the Vernor test does, right?
It says as long as you recite
the right kinds of restrictions.
As long as you announce your
intention to restrict use,
to restrict transfer and you
call this thing a license
and not a sale, you get your wish.
Of course the context in which the
transaction occurs is important
and some of that context is going
to be reflected in the license.
But we can't stop there, right?
My beef with the Crawls
decision is in part a question
about terminology, right?
I think this term license
copy is misleading
in an important way, right?
It distracts our attention
from what the real question is,
which is whether or not a
transfer of ownership has occurred.
And I think the more familiar
transactional category is a really
much more useful than the
term license and figuring it
out the answer to that question.
The statutory language, rental lease
or lending I think is much more
effective, because a license
as we know this is one of
the beauties of licenses is
that they're infinitely
flexible, right?
Property transactions are
not infinitely flexible,
certainly not property transactions
when it comes to personal property.
There's a limited number of accepted
transactional forms and what we have
to do is look at a set of facts
including the text of the license
and decide which category
works, right?
The numerous clauses principle
applies in this context as much
as it does anywhere
else in property law.
Does that get to your question?
>> Sy Damle: Yeah, yeah.
And so this sort of I'm
trying to sort to see
where if there's any real
disagreement between you
and Mr. Mohr in terms of,
you know, Mr. Mohr said,
it might be appropriate,
would be appropriate to look
at again going back to
the topic of the study
which is software-enabled
consumer products which is it's--
it may be irrelevant
consideration to look
at whether what you're talking
about is software that's embedded
in a product when you're
trying to determine, you know,
under a test like Crawls whether
something is owned or not.
>> Aaron Perzanowski:
So I would not--
I don't think the question
of ownership hinges
on whether the software
is embedded in a device.
>> Sy Damle: I wasn't suggesting
it was, but I was suggesting
that it might be a relevant factor
and it might be an important factor.
Just going to the point that
it gives you an indication
of what the customs are, what
the consumer expectations are,
which I think something Mr. Mohr
agreed with be-- also relevant.
>> Aaron Perzanowski: Yeah, I think
it could be a relevant factor,
I don't think it's the
driving factor that the things
that I've talked about
before, one time payment,
perpetual possession I
think are much more clear
or much clearer indications of
the answer to that question.
But I think that context
is important
that there might be reasons to treat
some kind of products and some kind
of industries different from others.
Thank you.
>> Eric Bertin: So just to,
take a jumping off point
from what Sy just said
in the legislative--
legislation for 117 that there's
a carve-out for embedded software
in devices in the context
of rentals, the notion being
that you can rent the car
and you don't need to worry
about the software in it.
And in a legislative history
there's reference as examples
of such devices on microwave ovens.
And I guess, you might look to
that and say well Congress has sort
of recognize that that's an
issue and they've carve that out
and that would give us useful
information about what has happened
since that change or
that provision was added.
And I guess the question
generally for the panel is does
that give useful information
from experience or is it the case
that that change is
really irrelevant
because again getting back
to the ownership question
if you don't own the software,
you don't own the machine,
it's the provision is
essentially doesn't do the work
that it may have been
intended to do.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: Well I think
it's helpful in that it shows that,
you know, at the time it was
certain industry group came forward,
the rental car industry and
said hey this is a problem,
and Congress address that
problem and the sky didn't fall.
And we're now, you know, the
economy is in a different place
and the level of technology
and the level of the number--
the kinds of devices that have
software in them are-- is different.
And so, you know, I think it
certainly worth looking and says,
you know, well that's a good
starting point but now, you know,
that only applies to the rental
of devices that have or, you know,
that have the software in it and
so it's worth saying, OK can we--
does it make sense to expand
it beyond the rental context
to other context, and does it make
sense to perhaps consider, you know,
expanding it to the universe
of software, I mean, you know,
the definition that they have or,
you know, the category of software
that applies so it's kind of hard
to understand what
exactly what it means and,
y even with report language,
it's hard to understand
but I think it has been applied.
People know I think that people
basically understand what it's
applied to and it has not as far
as I'm more led to any litigation.
But, you know, I think it's
certainly worth saying, OK,
this is a good starting
point, you know, how do we--
how can we expand on that, and how
can we build on that given the fact
that the world has
moved forward from there
and the issue is far more pervasive
in the economy that
it was at the time.
>> Mr. Kupferschmid:
>> Keith Kupferschmid: So, just
to follow up on your example
of the microwave in the context
of what Jonathan just said,
I mean the Congress knew
microwaves had software back
when they passed the act.
Microwave still have
software in them,
not sure what in that
context is changed
and what's Congress understood
the issue, they knew the issue
and decided to limit
this carve-out to rental.
And so I think until we have vary
sort of specific concrete examples
of problems I think it would
be in the stake to sort
of legislate in this arena.
I'd also like to point out
in the context of the--
of 109 and we talked about licenses
as if they were a four letter word,
and as if the mere fact that
there is a license in place means
that you can't do X, Y and Z, that
you could do if you were an owner,
and that simply isn't the case, and
maybe the case sometimes but I think
in the vast majority of examples or
at least I think we need to study
of all the different consumer
products that are out there
and that includes software
to figure out how many
of them actually do
restrict transfer.
And of those products that restrict
transfer, how many of them just sort
of condition transfer like
for into the allow use.
A lot of software companies for
instance that allow the transfer
of their software provided you let
them know who you're transferring it
to and so they know who
to give the updates to
or the bug fixe or what have you.
And so I think what you'd see
as if you look at these licenses
that they are, numner1, not those
restrictions on things like,
you know, essential copies, not
those restrictions on transfers
that you think that people
think that might the other.
And you might even find a lot
of provisions in those licenses
that provide benefits
that are not found
in the usual ownership
or contract agreement.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: That's like--
>> Your mic.
>> Chris Mohr: Just I guess
a couple of points in light
of the discussion that's going on.
The first thing is I
do see some overlap
between Professor Perzanowski
and I on the--
at least in so far as the
concept to relevance goes.
When the-- when we get
to the concept of weight,
I think we have probably
considerably different views.
The second thing that struck me is
in discussing the drafting of 117,
I-- like everybody else, I
don't know how it got there,
I suspect Mr. Band
is probably right.
And if he is right, then the
development of the licensing model
for software was part
of congressional design.
This was not an oversight.
And so, if we're doing that,
I mean again I'm-- this is--
the office is doing its job if
I'm coming back to the same point
that I-- in the beginning we've been
thoroughly examining these issues,
but again there's an enormous
record of success here,
and how that model has played
out for software providers.
To that end, I guess
I feel obligated
to voice extreme skepticism about
the idea of any sort of preemption
of license terms that's
just not something
that serves this industry well
for the whole host of reasons.
>> Sy Damle: So there are--
there is at least one case,
maybe more that have actually
preempted license terms
in a couple of context?
>> Chris Mohr: Oh,
there's more than one.
>> Sy Damle: Yeah, so
I mean, what do think?
I mean what of the ill
effects of that-- of those?
>> Chris Mohr: If you're
saying-- there are certain cases.
So under the-- there are--
well, there's a couple
different kinds of preemptions.
There is statutory, right, and
then you have field and conflict.
I'm assuming you're talking
about statutory preemption cases?
>> Sy Damle: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
>> Chris Mohr: OK.
So the-- with respect to the
statutory preemption cases,
there is a dividing line that
we've historically not really had a
problem with between-- oh, I'm
trying to remember the exact words
but essentially it's a qualitative
test that the courts have applied.
And there's a difference for
example between use restrictions
and copying restrictions.
And if you have copying
restrictions and the court looks
at those particular cases of scants
and if you have use restrictions
and they don't, that's an
appropriate and workable line,
that's a quite different matter from
a statue that preempts contracts
or specific type of contract
for a particular industry.
It's very, very different.
So we're OK.
I mean, we're OK with existing law.
We don't have a problem with
it, but when we're talking
about in this discussion
moving beyond that,
that's where the hackle
starts to go up.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Zuck?
>> Jonathan Zuck: Yes, thanks.
Thanks again for allowing me
to be part of this conversation
and it's very interesting to find
the intersections between sort
of the practical implications
and some of these deep dives
into the legal discussions.
And so taking a step back again,
I just want to reiterate
what Chris said,
which is that we have a system
that's already working in terms
of software licensing and in
terms of serving the needs
of the majority of consumers, right?
In other words, most consumers
have a particular mode of operation
and don't have assumptions about
if I buy an app on my phone
that app will transfer with
the phone if I give the phone
to someone else for example.
And so it ends up being
exception cases that I feel
like we're talking about a lot.
And so when trying to address those
exception cases, I think it has
to be weight against the
success of the industry to date.
And also some of the flexibility
and again the dynamism associated
with those licensing practices.
So I mean, when I sell a piece
of software, a game or something
like that, that for 99 cents
I do it with the expectation
that you will probably tire
of that game eventually.
So the point on which of tired
of that game is what I consider
to be the duration of the
life cycle of that game.
It's not how long somebody--
indefinite number of
people could be interested
into that game into
the future, right?
I mean, it's so-- when I'm pricing
at 99 cents I'm sort of building
into that notion that well,
after six months you're going
to either stop playing
this or you're going
to buy new levels or
something like that.
I'm not building into a 99% cost
the ability for an infinite number
of people to become bored with
that game, and so there's this--
there is some expectations and some
of this dynamic licensing models
that says that I understand
how users are going
to go about using it.
And then, you know, again in
the context of embedded devices,
which is where we have the least
amount of information about this,
I think because there's a
least amount of licensing cases
that have been addressed
and situations but,
if I say just automatically
that if you buy a refrigerator,
you all know the software in the
refrigerator doesn't that mean
that I can carry that software into
another refrigerator for example
that I buy or does the lifetime
of the software die
with the refrigerator?
Well, if I own the software,
then why don't I have the ability
to transfer that to another
refrigerator that I want
to use instead but with this
software that I somehow own
as a result of purchasing
a refrigerator.
So I can see a lot of--
>> Sy Damle: That's not-- It's
not particularly realistic
for a consumer.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Well, no, it's--
well, not particularly realistic
for consumer but that's just it.
Most of these cases that we're
talking about aren't consumer cases.
They're about very large industries
that are trying to commoditize
out on products, after
market et cetera.
It's very seldom about a consumer
doing any of these things.
So in that case I could
very much see a situation
where I could take advantage of
ownership law, provide some way
that here is my new refrigerator
that's half price and here's a way
to transfer the software
out of this, you know,
refrigerator you own
before and you don't have
to buy another one or
something like that.
That could be done at a higher level
than just an individual consumer
and made pretty easy I guess.
I mean, you know it's a weird
example of the refrigerator
because it such a big device
but I mean it certainly could have
been the case with tvOS or something
like that, that where
a lot of that kind
of active hacking took place
even at a consumer level.
So I'm going-- Again, the
ownership of the software,
I think has downstream
consequences that we aren't--
that haven't fully thought
through, that's all.
Even in embedded devices.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Beckert?
>> Shaun J. Bockert: Thanks for
bringing that one up Mr. Zuck.
So maybe we can put a more
realistic face on it when we talk
about exchanging software
on parts in automobiles.
And so in this example where,
you know, somebody owns the copy
of the software on their automobile
and one of the parts malfunctions
but there's a piece of
software on that part, right?
And we'll imagine that it's
just a part that's not covered
by copyright so-- or covered
by patent, so it's just a screw
that has a piece of software
in it that communicates
with another screw just to say,
this is the correct approved screw
that contains, you
know, that's authorized
by the automobile manufacturer.
Well, you know, if the
software is not there
and after market parts manufacturer
can come in and say I can make
that screw, we're going to put that
screw and you have several options.
But in the scenario where, you know,
the owner of the automobile
does not own the software
and does not have the right to
transfer the copy of the software
into the new screw, now they don't
have options for replacement screws,
they have to go to the
person who owns the copyright
and the software and the screw.
And it's not, you know, you say,
maybe in the refrigerator market,
you know, this is sort
unrealistic and it's impracticable--
impractical or think about this.
But, you know, the after market
auto part industry is a $350
billion industry.
I mean, this is something that
exists and that's changing because,
you know, of the prevalence
of software in these
that is purely mechanistic in parts.
So I think it's a very real concern.
>> Jonathan Zuck: And I think
that a lot of that is going
to get adjudicated over time
and we've seen already cases
where pure interoperability has
fallen in favor of even replacement,
printer cartridges and
things like that that--
so I think the systems that are in
place are addressing those issues.
I'm-- Let me think of
another example that cameras,
right, I'm a photographer.
If I buy the Canon 5D Mark II, it
has a certain amount of firmware
on it that provides a
certain functionality.
There's other cameras
that they sell--
the only difference of them is
in fact the firmware, right?
And that it is probably additional
functionality provided to the owners
of those cameras and the difference
between them is in fact the software
and not the hardware because it's
simply easier to fully implement it
and to provide different
firmware than it is
to have different manufacturing
practices.
So if I own the firmware associated
with the more expensive camera,
can I then later upgrade
to a cheaper camera
and install the firmware
from the previous one.
I would consider that to be a
bad, you know, potential and
yet firmware is something
that's completely transferable
and is done by users today, right?
So it's not unimaginable, right?
And so, I mean, I'm just-- if we're
having a theoretical discussion
about it.
I can come up with as many
theories why I don't want
that transferability as you
can come up with the due.
I guess my understanding of what
has happened historically though is
that the things in
which we would all kind
of agree would be a good
idea, the courts have ended
up ruling in that direction.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Bergmayer?
>> John Bergmayer: All the examples
you're bringing up are not transfers
of material items, they're
all about making new copies,
they're all about making
adaptations,
they're all about things
that really don't relate
to whether or not you own the copy.
Owning a copy of a 99 cents
software app would only mean
that you could transfer your
phone, your physical phone,
it doesn't give you the magical
right to make an infinite number
of new copies to anyone
else who wants one.
If I own a refrigerator that
doesn't give me the right
to transfer the software because
it would give me the right
to move the chips from one
refrigerator to another, sure,
but not to make a new copy and
the same thing with the firmware.
So I think there's just a failure
to distinguish between ownership
of a copy which is a material
thing and then the implication
of actual copyright rights under--
such as reproduction or derivative
works, and if those are allowed,
those would be allowed under fair
use, or maybe they are allowed
under some other doctrine
but whether
or not you own the copy
really has no bearing.
Owning the copy doesn't means
that you own the physical
thing and that's it.
And it means that you can move that
physical thing around and resell
that physical thing it's not about
giving you IP rights of any sort.
>> Jonathan Zuck: On the flip side
of that though if I license software
for example, and I-- and
again, this is an embedded
but I would use the examples
that I'm drawing from.
I have the ability to install
it on to new device for example.
So if I'm only confined to my
ownership of the copy that exist
on a single device and I then
sell that device and get a new,
the iPhone or something like
that, that would suggest
that I don't then have a
right to bring a new copy
of software unto that device.
You can't have your
cake and eat it too.
>> John Bergmayer: If I buy
software-- if I buy physical--
if I buy optical media then I'm
given an essential step copy--
>> Jonathan Zuck: You're
not of a topical.
You're downloading it from
a store to your phone.
>> John Bergmayer: Yes.
>> Jonathan Zuck: So, you're saying
that that's the things
that you want to own?
OK, I'm--
>> John Bergmayer:
Yes, I own my phone.
>> Jonathan Zuck: OK, so--
>> John Bergmayer: I already
owned my phone and I own it
after installing software.
>> Jonathan Zuck: But you
want to own that software.
>> John Bergmayer: Yes.
>> Jonathan Zuck: That
you've downloaded.
OK that's fine then when you get a
new phone then you have to pay me
to get the software
again for the new phone,
that's what you're suggesting.
>> John Bergmayer: There are
markets that work that way
and there are markets that don't.
I mean there are markets that
give you unlimited redownloads
on to new physical
devices that you own--
>> Jonathan Zuck: And that's
because it's a license.
>> John Bergmayer: Right.
So what I bought then
is I bought the right
to make new reproductions--
>> Jonathan Zuck: You don't-- you
bought nothing, that's the point.
You've-- yes, you've bought
a license of the software--
>> John Bergmayer:
But I own the phone.
>> Jonathan Zuck: -- so that
regardless sometimes you can use it
on three different
devices for example.
>> John Bergmayer: If I own my
phone, I own a copy of the software
that is installed on that
phone because a copy is defined
in the statute as a material item.
There is no other category.
There is no ethereal copy
like right to own a copy,
right to make a new copy.
I can license IP rights or
I can own a physical item
and there is just a continual
failure to make that distinction
which is vital and specifically
the embedded software contexts
that we're here to discussion
because it's specifically implicates
the ability to transfer devices
with software that is embedded in
them from one person to another.
>> Jonathan Zuck: I guess
it hasn't been a problem--
that much problem doing
those transfers of devices
that happen but its software though.
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
I think we would say
that in the automotive industry
there have been those issues.
So we see that all the time.
>> Jonathan Zuck: You're talking
about the placement parts
though, it's a different--
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
Right but that--
>> Jonathan Zuck: --
issue than transferring.
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
But there are part--
so this gets to what John
was saying earlier about how
when you own the automobile, you
know, are we going to distinguish
between whether you own certain
parts and don't own other?
What we're saying is when you're
replacing a part the, you know,
there are restrictions that are not
allowing you to transfer the chip
that contains the software to the
other because you can't access it
and you can't get it to
reboot on the other--
on the replacement device.
>> Jonathan Zuck: Is it about
you transferring your chip
or building your own chip and yeah
the new screw that you're trying
to provide when you function
it and try to provide,
is it really about making a physical
transfer of a chip from one screw
to another that you're trying to--
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
It's both issues.
>> Jonathan Zuck: -- accomplish?
>> Shaun J. Bockert:
It's both issues.
>> John Bergmayer:
To me, I'll just say,
I'm actually adopting what I think
is a pretty narrow view of 109
because I am specifically not saying
that this is about digital for sale
which is some right which
people have proposed--
yeah, to make new copies.
This is about transferring a
material item from one owner
to another and that's it.
There are other issues that
are related to digital for sale
that we can discuss but specifically
when it comes to section 109
and the ownership of a
copy, it is only about the--
the ownership of a material item.
It is not about IP
rights and it is not
about anything sort
of broader than that.
And I think it is simply misleading
to suggest that saying that the fact
that someone owns a copy gives
them intellectual property rights
which would be a license that
they otherwise don't have.
>> Eric Bertin: OK.
I wanted to hit one other
topic before we close out,
and that's open source software
which is often accompanied
by conditions on the free transfer
and reproduction of such software
such as requiring the disclosure
of any software medications
or the downstream licensing
of such software.
And the question I'd like to
put out is YODA or an amendment
like YODA affect the development
and use of open source software?
Chris?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Mic again.
>> Chris Mohr: So this
question came up before
and the answer to that
question is yes.
And the reason is because
an owner of a copy
if I make a modification suppose
it's a fair use I have no obligation
whatsoever to share that.
I may in fact sell fair
uses of a particular works
without permission,
that's the point, right?
So under that type of
model that's undercuts.
That type of model rather undercuts
the incentives for communities
to develop around open source
and the sharing that goes
on in those communities to quickly
fix bugs and so on and so forth.
It's a very different way
of distributing software
and the current model
allows people to choose.
If they think that they
are going to do better
under an open source model,
they are free to do so
and to adopt any number of different
licenses whether it's the GPL
or another one, but.
And if they want to do a
close ecosystem in the way
that Apple does they
can do that too.
That's fine.
And it seems to have
worked pretty well.
The only way it doesn't work
I guess is if you are adopting
and I mean I don't know what more
I can say about differing ways
of construing the statute based
of the ownership and copy other
than if you don't-- other than
to really say, I don't agree.
I'm having trouble finding
a court case that agrees.
And there are lots of people who
have invested lots of time and money
and effort on particular
constructions of that very provision
that has been shown to
be an enormous success.
I think it would be unwise
to disrupt those expectations
or that performance.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: Yeah, I
don't see YODA or something
like that having any impact at
all on open source software.
As we heard before, you know,
the open source licenses are
affecting the rights attaching
to the software but not the copy
of the software because it's--
and so, you know, the open source
license allows the second user
to make copies or to make derivative
works, those are concluded different
from what we're talking
about in YODA which is purely
about can the first person sell
the product to the second person?
And it doesn't-- and it
would no way limit what's--
how the open source
model would work.
But also just getting back to the
previous colloquy about, you know,
let's say firmware
that is transferred
from one device to a newer device.
I mean, you see that all the
time with refurbished products.
And, you know, we think
that, that secondary market
for refurbished products is--
I mean that's a good thing.
It's positive for consumers
because, you know, you have--
consumers are able to buy
a product at a lower cost
than they would have been able to
buy a new or unrefurbished product.
And it's, you know, environmentally
good to recycle products.
And, you know, so yes it
means it conceivably means
that you'll have a manufacturer
who would have to compete
with a refurbished
product but, you know,
we think that competition is
good basically that in copyright
and other statutory monopolies are
the exception to the general rule
in our economy that we want
to promote competition.
And so, having refurbished
product is a good thing
and we should encourage
it as much as possible.
>> Eric Bertin: Mr. Perzanowski?
>> Aaron Perzanowski: So
I want to go back to--
to go back a few minutes to a point
that was made about the possibility
that at least some license
agreements grant consumers' certain
rights that might otherwise be
within their control
as owners of copies.
There are circumstances, right,
where a license does
provide something a keen
to the rights under
109 or 117, right?
That happens out in
the world sometimes.
And, you know, I think that's--
those kinds of flexible
licenses are a welcome addition
to what we see out
there in the market.
You know, so Amazon for example
has a sort of simulation of lending
that works on the Kindle.
So publishers can opt in for
some books to allow consumers
to lend an ebook one time
for a period of two weeks
and then never again, right?
And so there are I think two
important limitations to keep
in mind and I think
demonstrate why those kinds
of licensed secondary markets
are a pretty poor substitute
for the real thing.
One is they are incomplete, right,
Amazon system for example is opt in.
Not all platforms do this certainly
not all publishers participate,
so you get this sort of spotty
set of rights for consumers.
And the other I think more important
big picture thing is there's a big
difference between granted
permission to engage in a behavior
and having a right to engage
in that behavior, right?
Property is not having
to ask for permission
and that's why we care
about ownership.
And there are some really
important things that flow
from unregulated property
interest, right,
unregulated secondary markets.
We might think that those uses
are most variable precisely
where permission is not
going to be granted, right?
So, you know, you mentioned that,
you know, sometimes they say,
look yeah, you can sell your
software but like, you know,
write down who you're selling it
to and keep track of that transfer.
Well, you know, one of
the great things that come
from unregulated unlicensed
secondary markets is privacy.
No one keeps track of who owns what.
No ones keeps track of what books
you're reading, no one keeps track
of what software you're using
and I think consumers
see that as a benefit.
And you can think about user
innovation or, you know,
potentially competitive
uses that or, you know,
competitive resale markets
where it's really unlikely
that anybody is going to
give permission for someone
to take their product and build
on it and do something new
and interesting within where you
might not see permission to sell
or use product at a lower price
that competes with the new product.
But that's precisely what a property
interest allows owners to do.
So, those things do exist but
they are not a perfect substitute
for actual ownership by purchasers.
>> Eric Bertin: Chris-- Mr.
Mohr would you have one more--
one final thought?
Or Mr. Harbeson?
>> Chris Mohr: No.
In fact, I forgot to-- no.
>> Eric Bertin: Mister--
sorry, go ahead.
>> Eric Harbeson: It's
kind of ridiculous.
I'm glad I'm not going to be
the final word because it--
that'll be kind of silly, but.
I promise that I would shut up
and I did not sign a contract
to that effect so you're
stuck with one more of word.
I want to just go back to a couple
of things that were said earlier.
We-- There's been a lot of
talk or some talk anyway
about unintended consequences
of change in the law.
The Music Library Association is
here precisely because we're worried
about unintended consequences of
looking at something too narrowly
and having that to have
broader consequences.
So, just to be clear unless what
is recommended is something--
narrow to the extent of only
affecting 109C for example
and the way again that
legislation works,
I think that's unlikely
making a change
in this small field will
have larger ripple effects.
So please I implore the office
to consider the wider impact
of what they're recommending.
The other thing I want to address
is the question of preemption
of contracts and the reason I want
to do that is because we are--
we do propose a form of
that but I want to be clear
that we do not support for example
what was done in the United Kingdom
which renders certain
contracts unenforceable
if they contradict limitations
and exceptions in their law.
That would cause enormous
problems for us in negotiations
of gift agreements into like the--
what we are requesting is a
much narrower form of preemption
and I would like to just
underline that proposal.
It's in our initial
comments and so I just would
like to point towards that.
>> Eric Bertin: And Mr.
Kupferschmid, you get the last word.
>> Keith Kupferschmid: OK.
So just to point out on a sort
of inconsistency with what
at least what I'm hearing from,
say the other side of the table.
We hear that consumers
have a right to privacy.
I understand that.
I get that.
We're also hearing that, you know,
they should have a right to updates
and bug fixes and customer support
as would be on the YODA bill.
You can't have it both ways.
I mean, there's no way for the
software company to know who am I,
know that the software has
been transferred and to know
who to provide these updates and
bug fixes and customer support
to if the individual wishes to
be remain anonymous or something
in terms of who you sell to.
So there's an internal inconsistency
there that is, you know,
that is problematic and I think
from a consumer protection or from,
you know, sort of satisfying
their customer base,
I think it makes a lot of sense
for these software companies
to includes a provision in there
that says, yes you can transfer.
We're giving you-- That's
what you want to do,
yes you can transfer the software
but under these circumstances
which is we need to know who you're
transferring it to so we know
who to deliver the consumer support
to the upgrades, the bug fixes.
I think that's completely
reasonable.
And to the extent we're
hearing otherwise,
it's sort of putting the software
companies in a no win situation.
And I guess that's the last word.
>> Eric Bertin: Thank you
to the members of our panel.
This concludes our roundtable on
software-enabled consumer products.
Oh, excuse me I'm being
corrected on that.
>> Sy Damle: So we have a microphone
setup free standing microphone.
We wanted to have sort of a
period of time for observers
and the audience to offer any
thoughts or comments they might have
so there's a mic stand that's making
its way to the front of the room.
So if anyone-- if anyone
is interested, go ahead,
where there's a microphone there.
Mr. Tepp?
>> Steve Tepp: Thanks-- is this on?
Is it on? Now there we go.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Steve Tepp: All right.
Just a couple of remarks
in regard to the harm
from the proposed contract
preemption concept.
I'd like to point out that commonly
in the business-to-business
context licenses are the result
of face-to-face arm length
negotiations and the preemption
of those contracts introduces
unnecessary uncertainty
into the market place
and is inconsistent
with the basic free market approach
of the US Copyright System
dating all the way back
to Article 1, Section 8, Clause 8.
In any event, what
this issue really boils
down to is preempting contract
terms that some people don't
like not withstanding the fact that
they're enforceable contract terms.
So it's about government
banning certain business models
which will actually have
the predictable effect
of increasing prices
because software companies
have fewer options and how
to tailor a license to particular
uses and they're be forced
to offer higher level,
higher price licenses.
And the case for government
control in place
of free market approach
simply hasn't been made.
The evidence is scant at best
particularly on the context
of software industry which
is as dynamic as competitive
and as innovative as any
industry in the Untied States.
Thank you.
>> Sy Damle: Any other
thoughts from the audience?
OK. Well, thank you that was the--
now that's the end of
the first roundtable
on software-enabled
consumer products
and next week in San Francisco.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit at loc.gov.